the plan here is just to say a couple
things about each of these and maybe
i'll go a little more in depth in the
doubly robust stuff
and the slides will be posted so i try
to provide enough detail for each of
these topics
so that who's over interested can dig in
on those and of course people
want references to papers or other
things please email me um
so okay so so one of the things that
that i think doesn't get
uh as much attention in rl as it does in
statistics especially biostatistics
is the idea of planning an experiment
and
you know we talk about sample size and
power calculations and biostats all the
time
but it does come up in rl applications
where suppose you want to test
an rl algorithm to make decisions in
some kind of uh
some kind of domain so maybe it's in
retail or something else
and they want to know well how much
experimenting do we have to do before we
can be sure that it's working or not
working and what kind of differences
should we
sort of be expecting to be able to
detect and so on
uh and so planning for sequential
decision problems
uh happens outside of biostatistics but
i'll give an example
in in in clinical trials because it's
it's certainly the most common but
it's becoming more important as we start
spending actual dollars to run
experiments to get information to build
decision support systems so i want to
say a little bit about that
and i won't go through the theorems uh
but i will just introduce the problem
and say something about uh the ideas and
the non-regularity stuff is in
all of this and so now hopefully there's
a little bit of a foundation
so that you can under you know see those
ideas being kind of
used throughout all these uh ideas so
here's an example of a treatment regime
for
an ms this is a mobile health
application for post-traumatic stress
disorder and cancer patients
this was sophia smith and
there's two decision rules here so this
is a two-stage decision problem the
first stage says if your distress score
is greater than three then you get
something called the cancer distress
coach this is the mobile health
intervention
uh otherwise if your ptsd symptom score
is more than 20 then you also get cdc
otherwise usual care this is the first
stage
rule the second stage rule it says if
you're responding then just continue
whatever you were doing
otherwise if you had started on cdc and
your ptsd symptom change is more than
three then add mobile coaching or m
coaching
also cd if you started on cdc and your
distress course now more than four
at facetime cognitive behavioral therapy
or facetime cbt
otherwise give facetime cbt only and
this rule
corresponds to data collected from
a sequential multiple assignment
randomized trial so this is um
uh a sequential uh trial where there's
multiple stages of randomization so you
can see here
um the schematic for the trial so the
the r's are for randomization
and so patients enter the trial the
randomized either the distress codes or
standard care
then there are sets for response and i i
think
i forget what response was here maybe it
was in six weeks with the responder then
they just continue what they were doing
but if they're not a responder they get
randomized a second time and you can see
there's different options going through
and so every patient that completes a
trial will end up in one of these
terminal
leaves in the tree determine those in
the tree
and we want to take data like this and
estimate a rule like this
or some other form and the question is
how many patients do we need
and what kind of guarantees can we
provide for a particular sample size
okay so this is this is asking you know
how many
how many patients do we need to recruit
or how many time steps do we need to
take
to ensure that we can estimate a rule
and then provide some guarantees for his
performance
uh so why is this a new and emerging
problem
the reason is that most of the time when
we run clinical trials in practice
the sample size is based on some very
simple primary comparison
or a primary aim and uh we power
meaning that we want to have a
sufficient power to do a hypothesis test
for something simple like compare the
mean outcome of two non-overlapping
treatment sequences meaning
you know no two if you take the two
patients to two
pools of patients who followed uh these
treatment sequences there's no overlap
so it's a simple t-test very easy
this is a very clear criteria for power
calculations
test statistics are standard there's no
non-regularity here very easy
and in practice estimation of a
treatment regime or an optimal policy
is some is often done in some kind of
secondary analysis
and the reasons are that that involves
composite hypotheses so if you want to
say something like
the optimal personalized treatment
strategy is better than business as
usual
that's a statement about the optimal
policy which we don't know and so it's a
it's a composite null
or a composite hypothesis rather that um
that that lives in the space of policies
right
uh so and it's unclear exactly which
criteria we should be using so you know
it should be one or two three
and what should they be and the test
statistics are non-regular as we've seen
so we want to talk about the value
function for example
that's not going to behave nicely and so
we can't use
sort of basic sample size formula so
what do people do now
uh they run their trial so they run a
smart they run their primary analyses
maybe they just compare the first two
treatments
they do a comparison of those two and
then they do a secondary exploratory
analysis for the estimated optimal
treatment regime or an optimal policy
say pi hat
maybe they do some kind of
cross-validation to get a sense for its
value
and if it looks promising then they run
a follow-up
randomized clinical trial where patients
are randomized either to the estimated
optimal regime that was estimated from
this data
and a control and then they compare
these two and because this is a new
batch of data
this is just a simple comparison of
you know treatment versus control and so
again it's standard and so we call this
the estimate and validate paradigm
uh and so you know this is
sound scientifically in the sense that
you're not using the same data twice
but it's potentially inefficient because
you've now run two distinct clinical
trials
uh and so there's higher costs there's
delayed clinical impact because anyone
who's run a trial before knows that it
takes years and years to sort of design
and get it funded and then run it and
now as a result
and push the results out into the
clinical literature and then finally
ultimately into practice
and another issue is that pi hat may be
of low quality and this is a concern
not just the medical world but any rl
problem so we didn't size a trial to
ensure
that pi hat would be near optimal
and so what can happen is that we didn't
get because we didn't power the first
trial pi hat may
be low quality and so we don't run the
follow-up trial
so we miss out on personalization and so
that's bad for patients
or it does look promising but it's still
far from optimal so then we run the
follow-up trial and it doesn't validate
so we fail
or it's not near optimal but it's better
than what we're doing now we run the
follow-up trial and then we decided
that pi has the strategy we're going to
follow in the future
even though uh it's very far from
optimal so we're leaving a lot on the
table so to speak
right and so the ultimate consequence is
poor patient outcomes and
potentially uh the la you know we're not
generating as much clinical knowledge as
we as we could
and so the ideal situation would be to
write a single trial that allows primary
aims
to be uh answered and addressed
and also estimate and evaluate an
optimal regime and in an industry
context
you might say look we should roll out an
rl based algorithm in the setting
and so what you might want to do is run
an experiment
where your randomly randomizing
treatment or maybe even you're
adaptively randomizing but at some point
you need to be able to say
at this time point i will be able to
compare the rl strategy
with business as usual and make a
determination and we'll be able to
decide and then move forward
and so well i'm talking about clinical
trials here the same thing happens
in in other applications
[Music]
uh and it maybe i should say it's
distinct from like um just having a
constantly adaptive
algorithm that just this is changing all
the time
these more discrete things often happen
in settings where you're trying to
replace a human system with an rl system
uh and so you want to do that
head-to-head comparison
okay and then you want to use the thing
that you've learned
uh okay so why hasn't this been done
before one reason is that identifying
subgroups
you know patients that will benefit from
a given treatment has a lot of negative
connotations so we all know about
the reproducibility crisis and some of
the scandals in terms of uh
data snooping and other things that have
happened in subgroup identification
uh there's a lack of reproducibility and
generalizability and
it's generally viewed as having lack of
rigor
and in the sort of clinical trials
dynamic street regimes community
uh there's a widely held belief that
sizing a child estimated optimal regime
would require either an enormous sample
size or would
you be unable to guarantee sort of
frequent
operating characteristics meaning
construct confidence intervals that
deliver the right coverage or tests that
have the right to say type 1 error
but are so powerful or that it would be
intractable without strong assumptions
it's a question from java that if you're
already online
why don't we just simply consider
continuous online adaptation
yeah so in some settings that's great
right so i think advertising you can do
that i think search you can do that
but if you have a team of human experts
and you and you're proposing something
new but there's a lot of pushback so
that could be a precision medicine or it
could be in retail or somewhere else
and basically you're going to the only
the only way forward
to to actually get something adopted in
practice is to say
we're going to run a bake off between rl
and whatever it is we're doing now and
we're going to do that for some fixed
amount of time
and we're going to specify ahead of time
what the results have to be in order for
us to decide
which way we're going to go uh then this
has the same kind of
feel uh and
i mean i i i agree sort of the from a
theoretical point of view all you really
want to do is just be constantly
climbing uphill
there's there's non-stationarity to be
concerned with there's all sorts of
reasons we're just being online all the
time is sort of the right thing to do
but it's not necessarily the thing that
will be done until there's sufficient
buy-in from the community
so that's the that's the reason really
and and that's what's happening here is
that uh you know
we can imagine a world in which you go
to see your doctor
they enter all your information into an
ipad or something and then it
immediately
looks to to sort of the state of
knowledge and it adaptively assigns you
a treatment randomly based on what it
thinks is best and also what's going to
generate information without much risk
to you
and like that that would be sort of an
amazing feature but so we still
have to do things in these discrete
chunks now like running trials
uh and the same thing happens in some
parts of industry too
does that help
yeah and there's another question i'm
not sure if i fully understand the
question but
is it useful to think of the following
as a clinical trial
what is that if the rl system can
demonstrate these results over this time
frame then it is comparably viable
so i think the question is can we sort
of generically think of this type of
situation where
we have a bounded time frame we have to
demonstrate that rl is better than
standard of care whatever business as
usual can you just always think that we
are sort of in a clinical trial setting
i do but i'm strongly biased i don't
know if it's
i don't know if it's useful as a general
rule but because that's where my
background is and where my experience
lies at least a lot of it
i often think of things that way
i also think it's important because when
you're doing these kind of comparisons
and you're comparing it against a person
making a decision there's a lot of
causal inference issues at play
so it is useful to have that mindset i
think because you know cause efforts are
so
ingrained in biostats literature because
uh you know they're they're not
they may be making decisions on
information that is not contained in the
data and that can really
cause uh bias to creep in and so on
so i think it's useful at least one
useful way to frame these things but
then
obviously there are very brilliant
people who think about it differently
and so
uh yeah i find it helps me think about
these problems but
um i guess it's not strictly necessary
okay uh all right so
in terms of of the goal here uh and i
won't get into the details because we're
running out of
time i just want to touch on all these
things but our goal is to develop a
sample size procedure
that ensures estimation and evaluation
of an optimal regime or an optimal
policy
that has performance guarantees so i'm
going to state what those those
guarantees are and then i'll just say
something about how we do it
uh and so uh we developed in the paper
uh
sample size procedures are two extremes
one where you make very strong
distributional assumptions that's one
route you can take
and this implicitly excludes all this
non-regular non-standard behavior we've
been talking about
or the other extreme we only require
moment and tail conditions
and we don't require any of the models
to be correct
and we allow for non-regularity and
non-standard behavior and we still
provide
correct sort of sample size procedures
and then the idea is like you can
interpolate between these
so i just want to say what the uh so
we're
i'm going to skip ahead and just say
what are the criteria these are the two
criteria
so i'm just going to read these off and
then all these constants will become
clear as i read them off
so we want to be able to choose a sample
size n so that there exists an
alpha level test of the null that the
value of the optimal policy is less than
whatever we're doing now so the this is
this b
zero is like is the performance of
business as usual
right so the null is that we aren't
going to do any better by personalizing
and we want power at least one minus
gamma uh
provided that in fact personalizing is
at least eta better than what we're
doing now so we want a certain level of
power
if in fact there is a difference of at
least ada in terms of performance
uh and the second criteria is that you
want the
probability that the performance of your
estimated rule
is within epsilon of the true optimal
with probability at least one minus zeta
so you want n so that both of these
things happen one you can say is it
worth personalizing in this context
and two if it is
the rule i learned i want the rule i
learned to be very near to optimal with
high probability
and so in the remainder of this section
we go through how to do that and the way
that we do it
is through confidence intervals for the
difference
between v opt and beta0
and the idea is that if the confidence
interval with
is less than eta for the difference
then if the confidence interval doesn't
contain uh beta0
if you have a capacitor for v b pi opt
then you can reject the hypothesis and
you can also show that it has the right
power
uh and the second thing is we use
uh we basically bound the difference
between v of pi hat
and v of pi opt in terms of the
difference between
uh v of pi hat and and um sorry
v hat of pi hat and v
hat of pi ops we use a concentration
inequality there
um so uh i wanted to bring this up
because
this is one tiny problem that we talked
about with two stages
but this idea of how do we size studies
for estimation and mdp
and and more general settings i think is
an open problem
i think even in things like you know
bandits
oh uh there's a question i'll answer in
a second you know for bandits we know
how to do inference
in terms of if you have a linear band
let's say you can you can do estimation
and uh you can use sort of standard
methods to get confidence intervals for
the coefficients
let's say but uh
we we don't sample size calculations i
think are still kind of an open problem
and especially for mdps
uh and say palm dps and so i think
there's still
a ton of work to be done there and if
you're using
you know uh not a randomized policy but
using some kind of online learning
algorithm for a finite time horizon and
then doing these kind of tests
so um i think there's a lot of sort of
interesting mathematical problems
conceptual problems
but there's a question it says isn't
there moral dilemma that discourage
online learning and medical care
uh yeah so so the question there is um
there's certainly debate about uh
adaptive
randomization in these trials uh
so what do people do in practice well
one i mean the idea is that you're
that that some will argue
and it's been argued that if you do this
adaptation in a clinical trial setting
so here i'm not talking about that here
i'm just talking about a randomized
trial but if you're doing adaptively
randomized trial
uh that you try to argue it's at least
better
it is better than a randomized trial so
if the alternative is
you can do thompson sampling versus
you're going to do just
you know coin toss that on
average the number of patients who get
the best treatment will be higher in the
thompson sampling
case than the uh rent the simple coin
toss so people will make that argument
so peter thaw has has
designed trials this way and then made
that kind of argument
in cancer uh then there's also but then
there's the flip side which is
what about the future patients so if i
do some kind of adaptation am i then
going to hurt
uh future patients by generating less
information so
uh they don't in a clinical trial
setting
i don't have the question in front of me
now but you know there was this part of
it was well if you're just
giving them a suboptimal treatment for
information gain
if you deliberately gave them the wrong
thing for information gain even though
you thought another treatment is better
that would be
certainly a problem but that's what in a
randomized trial
you're just tossing a coin and the
purpose is information generation for
future patients
uh and and so you are trading
information for
um immediate reward although you know
you're supposed
the idea is you're also an echo poise so
you really aren't
deliberately giving them something you
think is worse so if anything though if
you're running an adaptive clinical
trial you should be increasing the
probability of giving them
the thing you think is better so i hope
that helps there's a lot there's a lot
of interesting kind of
debates that still go on if you look up
the sort of ethics of adaptive clinical
trials
and i'm sure i'm you know not getting
all the nuance that the clinicians like
to think about but um
yeah so there's a clarification question
for this slide
when you say pi opt like is it is it
within a class is it
is it the op value function yeah what's
the definition
yeah so it depends on the
on the setting so uh
if you're going to put a whole bunch of
distributional structure on everything
then it can be the true optimal overall
but of course you've put all this the
structure that implies
a very restricted class of policies
because you've put a bunch of parametric
structure on the data generating model
in the non-parametric case we don't make
any of those assumptions
this is going to be the population
analog of whatever algorithm you're
using
which may not be optimal it may not even
be optimal in the class because you have
this mismatch between say the estimation
procedure
and the true optimum right so it will be
it'll be defined as the population
analog of your estimator
so if the models are correct then this
will be the true optimum otherwise it'll
be
whatever your algorithm is going to
converge to with an infinite amount of
data
other questions
okay so i'm going to skip i'm going to
skip ahead uh
okay and i want to talk about the next
thing here which is
infectious disease i feel like that's uh
that is a thing that we can all relate
to so
um
obviously we're not thinking about white
nose syndrome anymore because we're all
thinking about comed but uh i got
involved in the spatial temporal
decision making through ebola and
through
white-nose syndrome and malaria and now
we have been working a little bit on
koben
but uh there's i think there's just a
lot of interesting open problems
in the spatial temporal decision-making
sort of world
and so the just the background here uh
the problem we're working on is this
fungus that kills bats
and uh it hasn't been in the press
lately because now there's
obviously uh much more human threatening
diseases but it's pretty it's pretty
devastating in terms of bad populations
it kills millions of bats
um and here's a picture of a bat with
white nose syndrome so that's
this sort of white stuff on its muzzle
here and on its wings that's this fungus
that grows on them
and so we were approached uh
by u.s fish and wildlife about where
they should put these artificial caves
so these are the interventions
and if you see this little figure here
that's a human so you can see how big
these things are
so they're very expensive and they the
the idea of these artificial caves is
they can clean white nose syndrome off
the bats and off the walls and so on in
an
artificial cave where they can't in a
naturally occurring
hibernacula or whatever so
the question was you know where should
we put these to control the spread of
this disease over you know it's
spreading across the united states
and uh you know part of the issue is
that we don't
know much about the disease and so you
know even as recently as when we were
working on this
uh they had the disease have been
spreading for a few years and they still
didn't know whether it could spread in
the summer or not
bats are very hard creatures to study uh
so but i want to give a sense for like
what the rl problem is and why i think
this is an interesting area that
could use more eyes and brains here is
that
so here's the obvious united states and
i've marked
uh these little outline regions here
these are counties that have
hibernating bats that are susceptible to
this disease this is a disease that
affects
hybridizing bats of certain species it's
color coded by year of infection
so the outbreak here was in 2006
uh in chivalry county new york by
remembering that correctly
and then it spreads across the northeast
and starts to go across the northwest
now it's in texas uh it's in oklahoma
but so you see disease spreading and the
question is okay so if i tell you the
status of the disease i tell you
something about each of these counties
and you have a very limited number of
interventions you can apply suppose you
can pick a subset of 10 of these
locations or
20 of these locations and apply an
intervention to slow the spread of
disease where should you put them
right and so this has a lot of
interesting components one there's the
spatial dependence part
so there's there's spillover effects
that happen right there's spatial
dependence
there's obviously the the disease
dynamics the underlying genetic model
itself is
spatial temporal uh there's high cost of
the treatments
it's a combinatorial problem so if you
have you know i think this is 1100
counties or something
and you can intervene and say 20 of them
that's an enormous action space
uh and then there's also lots of uh
partial observability here you know the
the way that they find out an infection
is in one of these locations actually
you know somebody goes out and crawls in
a cave and looks to see if the infection
is there so there's all sorts of false
reporting
um and so it's a really complicated
messy problem
and uh i just think there's a lot of
room here in terms of like
feature generation in terms of like
graph embeddings to construct write
features for q learning
i think the calls of inference side with
spillover uh
is really interesting uh so i was hoping
to get people excited about this
obviously with covid there's there's
tons of uh
problems that are relevant you know for
our daily lives um
so what is it what is the strategy here
what is the policy it's a map from the
current epidemic status like this
to a subset of counties that we mark as
high priority for treatment
um is there a well-defined trade
is the question that's come in is there
a well-defined trade-off between
evaluating interventions in terms of
slowing spread
and modeling dynamics uh
yes it's a great question so the so
the ecologists want to know about the
disease dynamics
right but i think that the policy makers
want so that is slow the spread of the
disease over some time horizon
and they don't care at all about
learning these dynamics so
the the people who are funding
intervention strategies are worried
about the billions of dollars in like
economic i mean uh agricultural impacts
because bats eat insects and insects
destroy crops and when the bats go away
we have to use more insecticide
and um anyway so uh so there
so there's not a trade-off that i think
anyone would agree on so most of these
problems have multiple stakeholders who
disagree in what
the priority should be so you know here
we're looking at minimizing
the some costs the cost could be
number of infected individuals or it
could be
just a geographic footprint of the
disease or some measure of economic
impact or it could be a composite
outcome with like economic impact
number and then maybe uh say ecological
diversity
uh impact on that and just so you can
come up with some kind of composite and
then settle on it but i don't think
you know if you looked at all the
different stakeholders they'd all give
you different objectives so here we
looked at the
number of infected counties uh as our
objective but
there are certainly other choices
[Music]
okay so there's lots of problems like
this obviously the spread of human
disease ecological management so looking
at you know
where we should create conservation
areas
precision agriculture is really a cool
area where they look at how to put
nutrients into soil they can do it at a
um
you know one-inch granularity or
something now it's pretty amazing and
they also have
if you haven't seen this these adaptive
targeted
uh pesticide placements it's not related
to this necessarily but it's a pretty
cool precision agriculture application
uh airline planning so we've worked on
um intervention strategies for
uh airline planning where you might want
to cheat you might want to change
how much time a plane spends on a ground
or how much time a crew has to get from
one fight to the next
uh in terms of reducing uh delayed
flights and delayed arrivals and
departures
okay so why is this an interesting
problem uh well when you have a new
new disease a new outbreak uh there's
very little or no data on intervention
effectiveness
right you have noisy incomplete sparse
measurements it's very high dimensional
in white nose syndrome there's like 11
000 measurements
per time point uh looking at all the
features all the locations
uh online estimation means that we have
to decide what to do
from a continually changing data
dependent strategy as you all know
but this means the sampling
distributions are complicated uh in
terms of computation this is a
combinatorial decision problem so
there's two to the l
possible allocations if you don't have
any constraints and so enumeration here
is not possible
uh and so you know how do we make
progress in these kinds of problems
uh so uh what's
sort of what we have done so far has
been
in two very simple things one is uh
looking at just modeling the dynamics
and then doing model-based planning
that's the first thing
and the second thing is estimating
equations uh
based on on cue learning uh and then
doing some kind of thompson sampling uh
in that space
we managed to get some some regret
balance and some rates of convergence
here
uh but there's still big open questions
about
you know how do we how do we do
meaningful inference how do we extract
uh domain relevant content about
what these policies are doing
differently than human experts and like
how do we
how do we take away sort of lessons
learned
so that we can help people improve their
intuition as they're making decisions
about these kind of problems
and that's clearly a problem with covet
right so the people
decision makers are trying to decide you
know whether we should
keep things closed you know mask
policies and so on
uh and you know how do we take rl type
algorithms and then extract kind of
information that they can use to make
their own decisions so it's not
necessarily
so here in white nose when it's an
disease with animals
you have a lot more freedom to make
interventions so we're running and
running one of these now with pigs we
just got funded in north carolina
where we can actually tell them what the
intervention is where to apply it
and then they'll just do that but with
obviously with human diseases that's not
how it's
uh often going to work and so we want to
come up with models that
generate new information that can be
useful in informing sequential decision
making
so i just want to show i'm just going to
show two pictures
the first one the model-based planning
what do we do is we posit
uh disease dynamics models which we
estimate with maximum likelihood
then we do simulation optimization with
the estimated disease models
to estimate an optimal uh
action which we then follow then we
observe the next state we just go round
and round
right one thing that happens here i
should say is we do maximum likelihood
estimation but then
we sample parameter values that index
our dynamics models from the sampling
distribution
for the maximum likelihood estimator as
a very poor man's way of doing thompson
sampling
so we don't have a proper prior or
posterior we don't want to parameter
we don't want to we don't want to run
mcmc in these contexts it's very
expensive
and so here we do the maximum likelihood
and then use the
the sampling distribution as a surrogate
for a posterior and draw
our dynamics model which is indexed by
these two parameters from that sampling
distribution treat those as truth
then the model based planning get our
optimal uh rule
and then choose action according to that
rule and then continue so
uh i just wanted what do you mean by
sampling distribution from the maximum
is it are you running a bootstrap or uh
so so
we're using actually a you could do you
could do a multiplier bootstrap for um
for martingale different sequences you
could do that here we're using an
asymptotic approximation
to uh to the sampling distribution
because we have a smooth
smooth likelihood and so we're just
doing that we're using um
results for the distribution the mle for
dependent data
so unlike the earlier parts of the talk
here the asymptotic distribution is
actually part of the method
uh that's right yes that's right and
also because we're doing maximum
likelihood without there's no bellman
sort of equation in here and so
these are nicely behaved two so we can't
get the sampling distribution and sample
from it
and the likelihood estimation is on the
underlying dynamics
model that's right why there's no max in
that that's just uh
some parameterized set of dynamical
and systems question was when we say
observe s is this from the dynamics
model from the real world this is from
the real world
so you make the decision and then you
actually see what the next state is
so this is happening in in the real
world
[Music]
okay uh and you can get some so there's
some bounds there which i'm not going to
go through
we've had enough math today i think so i
just want to say the other picture
uh is this is exactly what you were
getting at is
sort of a bootstrap so now we have an
estimating equation like we had before
uh and we perturb it with multiplier
weights which we then solve
uh for an optimal policy so we have to
do some optimization to actually solve
the
the term decimating equation get a
policy
take the action according to policy
observe the next state build the
estimating equation which we perturb
using multiplier bootstrap weights
solve it get a new policy and continue
this so this is a semi-parametric
variant of thompson sampling
where again we've used a sampling
distribution of the
parameters indexing the q function as a
surrogate for a posterior
and uh because we didn't want to this is
trying to avoid modeling system dynamics
um and so this is uh this is another
sort of
the reason i wanted to show this uh is
to show that there's also a lot of room
for improvement right so this is one
very simple thing you could do
which is q learning with uh with some
kind of perturbation to induce
uh uncertainty so that you continue to
explore
but i think that um
in these animal diseases this is all
fine but i think that there's a lot of
context where they're going to want a
deterministic algorithm
something like ucb or something like a
rollout where
where the if you fed the same data into
the algorithm you would always get the
same answer back
and and so i think that that's a that's
a big open area here because i think
running those kinds of designing those
kind of algorithms for these spatial
temporal settings
is not necessarily easy uh because of
the combinatorial aspect so if you're
gonna try to to maximize directly over
all possible
uh actions it's a huge space and it's
not these things are not um
sub-modular or anything so it's not it's
not
trivial to do that so i think there's a
lot of room here
to improve uh you can get some um
i didn't put it in the slide but you can
get some theoretical results for that
too
okay so now i want to slow down a little
bit
and and get into this uh wait
hang on i'm going to get into
i'm in the wrong spot here sorry i'm
going to get into the double audio
robust stuff here
a little concerned that i have the same
slides but okay
i somehow got flipped back in time here
okay
there we go okay so doubly robust
methods for model free and model
based so this comes out of the spatial
temporal problem
uh and although of course it's of
interest in other places
so one of the things in these disease
models is there are these disease
ecologists who have their
pet dynamics models so they build these
compartmental models of the disease
and they believe in these models and and
if they
and if they think if their model's not
right then there's some other variant of
it that is right
and so uh this is really nice for for
uh early on in an intervention process
because you don't have any data you got
to bring
you have to bring structure in from
somewhere and so bringing it in from
these domain experts
it's really useful but there's also this
obviously this fear that by relying on
these models that are heavily
parameterized and are almost surely
incorrect
that you eventually as data accumulate
uh
you know you would like to move away
from that and go to one of these model
free methods
and so one thing i've always wanted
is a doubly robust method that that will
work if you have either model based or
model free so there's doubly robust in
the sense that if you don't know the q
function or don't know the propensity
score
then you get correct inference here i'm
saying yeah if you have a dynamics model
and then you have a q let's say a q
function or a value function model
if one of those is right then you all
then you get the same answer and you and
then if they're both right you get
efficiency
so it's a little bit different than
normal w robust
stuff that we see
and at least in some cases so okay
just a quick review but i think model
based what do i mean i mean you estimate
the system dynamics and then you do
simulation optimization or some kind of
you use those model dynamics
to to estimate the optimal rule uh
and you impose structure that offsets a
lack of data so that's really important
in something like an epidemic
and you also leverage scientific theory
for the dynamics and that's really
useful so you're bringing this
additional information into the problem
uh we talk about model free i mean you
solve estimating equations for the
optimal policy without estimating the
dynamics
so you're imposing less structure which
is
potentially good but then you're also
you know potentially having more
more variance so you're trading bias for
variance
and it's harder to leverage the theory
in these kinds of problems
so you can obviously leverage theory for
feature construction so maybe they can
tell you what factors are important or
what interactions are or or you can try
to use some of those disease dynamics
models to like um
infer what uh what features might be
important but it's not
very easy and it's not so clear cut as
if they're telling you what the model
doesn't what the model is up to print up
to
a few unknown parameters so
uh can we somehow get the best of both
of these is
the idea and this is this is currently
in an open area
as i was saying to ambuj before this
started uh you know this is something
that that
you know we're working on now um so i
just wanted to sort of
brainstorm a little bit since i have uh
all of you here
um so uh
what do we mean well it's specified
dynamics model so typically we're
thinking a parametric model here it
doesn't have to be but i think
it's best to think about a parametric
model because i think that's the most
common case
and say some kind of a value function or
a q function or some kind of
semi-parametric type approach and the
thing that we want
we want to construct an estimator for pi
opt that is consistent if either but not
necessarily both
the dynamics model is right or the value
function is right
so this is the idea and if you get them
both right then you get an efficient
estimator
so this is this at least in the disease
dynamics model
context where you have somebody giving
you this parametric model
you're controlling their you're
controlling the action selection so the
propensity score is going to be right
because you know what it is it's in your
control
so if one of these is right you get the
right answer but if they're both right
you get you get efficiency so this is
this is the thing that
you want it's similar in spirit to w
robust estimators and statistics and
these have also been used uh
in in cs obviously uh emma and others
have worked on this and so
uh you should say cs also uh consistent
when either the propensity score key
function correctly specified and
efficient if both are correct um
so uh you know just
quickly uh here's the setup again this
is the same setup as we had before
suppose you have uh data s1
a1 through uh s-t-a-t
and then s-i-t plus one and so here i'm
assuming i-80
data drawn from uh some distribution p
it could be just one continuous stream
of data but i'm looking at the iad case
here
t is the observation period so that
could be some kind of
follow-up period for a clinical trial or
it could be
you know observation of interventions
for disease
and again t is a state a is set of
actions which here i'll just assume are
once uk
and the utility is some function of
state action next state code is that
higher is better
and we'll assume everything's uh
homogeneous and mark off
and we'll focus on deterministic
stationary policies pi which map states
to actions
okay so this is the setup uh and again
uh i won't go through the the technical
conditions i just want to sort of
give one idea here so look at the
discounted reward case so the value of
some state
s under action under policy pi is
expectation under pi
of the sum of gamma to
uh the discount factor raised to the v
power times u to the t plus v given the
current state
is s and an optimal regime here will
satisfy
v s of pi opt is greater than or equal
to v pi s for all s and pi
and then just a quick review of model
based estimation while we posit some
kind of model for the transition
dynamics
i'll assume that the initial state
distribution is known let's say uh
and it's indexed by some parameter theta
which lives in some parameter space
capital theta
you construct a likelihood there's other
methods of course but suppose you can
start to likely
l n of theta compute theta hat which is
a a root of the gradient of the
likelihood equal to zero or the log
likelihood set to zero
this should be equal to zero sorry and
um
a root of this and then for any pi we
can generate data under theta hat
this the maximum likelihood estimator to
construct an estimator say
v sub theta hat of s pi and
i'm going to assume that we're using you
know we're generating an enormous amount
of data with some very flexible
approximation architecture
so basically you get the value function
under this dynamics model
so i'm assuming you're going to generate
trillions and trillions of points and
you're going to use a very flexible
properly tuned neural network
and so this thing is the right value
function for this policy if these were
the dynamics
right just to simplify sort of
exposition here
okay so is that clear in terms of the
model based approach
i'm making this seem easy when of course
it's not uh but
conceptually it's easy i hope
um okay uh in terms of model free
estimation
here we're gonna look at the value
function so we'll posit some kind of
model for the value
that's indexed by some parameter say
lambda so that's a vector of parameters
and so for every pi you would have a
different lambda
and we solve estimating equations based
on the bellman optimality equation so
here
zero is equal to the empirical
expectation of the sum from t equals one
to t
of a point mass uh uh
this should be a point mass this thing
is one if
st is equal to pi of a t and zero
otherwise and this is the behavior
policy
the behavior policy is allowed to depend
on the entire history
and here's the utility at time t plus
gamma times the value of the next state
minus the value at the current state
times some weight function
okay so this just comes from taking the
the bellman equation for the value and
turning it into
an importance weighted estimating
equation
here and this is any function of st
and pi so remember part of our goal is
efficiency so we want to make sure that
we have an efficient estimating equation
here
so the question is what weight should go
here so
uh i have a paper on this
that uses one set of weights uh
that are not efficient um
so don't use those uh but it's
so what what which should we use well
the optimal weights say in terms of uh
you know the the theory of estimating
functions uh
you know gandambe and others
is the optimal weight psi st pi lambda
the expectation of the gradient of this
function
g i'll say what g is in a second
divided by the expectation of g squared
all given as so these are each given as
t so here
g is this term here
everything but this so g is the term
inside these braces times this
importance weight
okay so that's what g is this is a sum
of gt from
t equals one to t times this weight so
we're trying to figure out what this
should be
this is the function g so this is what
we should set
psi to be of course we don't know this
right we don't know now we're talking
about model free
so we don't know what what this
expectation is or this one
right uh but we do have a model
so here's the here's the nice thing this
is this will give us a consistent
estimator
uh if our value function is right no
matter what weights we put in here as
long as they're linearly independent
so we can put weights in here the only
difference is going to be how efficient
we are
so the efficient weights are given here
but if we put other weights we'll still
get consistency
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to estimate these expectations
using our model so what we'll do is
we'll cons we'll we'll take this
expectation with respect to our
estimated dynamics model
and this expectation with respect to our
estimated dynamics model and we'll put
that in as our weight
so the critical thing is if our model is
wrong if theta hat
you know if our model based on theta hat
is incorrect we'll just get an
inefficient
estimating equation that's still
consistent if our value function is
correctly specified
however if our model is correct then
these should be the efficient weights
at least they'll be converging to the
efficient ways
so we're going to plug those in here
okay so now how do we combine these two
things
so what we're going to do is we look at
a weighted estimator of this value
function
so it takes as input so it's a function
of s and pi
we have lambda hat which is a solution
to this with these estimated weights
uh psi of oops psi
of theta hat and so we have here is we
have
e to the alpha hat times some kappa n
i'll talk about these in a minute so
some weights times a value based on the
model plus one minus e to the minus
alpha k
kappa n times the value based on our
system dynamics model
right so we have a convex combination of
our two value functions
one is based on the model this one's
based on the estimating equation with
the efficient weights from the model
and so what you'd like to have happen
here
is that if the model is right then you
would like this term
to go to zero right
and so you put all your weight here and
if
the model is wrong you'd like alpha hat
times kappa to go to infinity and so
e to the minus that would go to zero and
so then all your weight would go here
okay so how do we choose alpha
so to choose alpha or alpha hat we're
going to set it to be the norm
of this estimating a function this
estimating function
but now what we put here for the value
is the model based
so this is an average over the data but
this is our model based value function
and this would be psi hat theta hat from
the previous slide here
sorry okay so or it could be any
function but that's the one we're going
to use here
so what happens if our model is
correctly specified
then this this will eventually be a root
it'll be an approximate root and
asymptotically will be a solution
to this estimated equation which means
that this term here
will be converging to zero as n diverges
if it's wrong and we have a unique
isolated minimizer of the bellman
equation
then this thing will converge to a
constant
so what happens is that if if we set
kappa
to diverge such that if this thing
converges to a constant then alpha
hat times kappa diverges to plus
infinity is obviously
not negative uh but we choose kappa
sufficiently slow
that if this thing is converging to zero
then kappa times
alpha hat still converges to zero so
this has to be growing
slow enough so that that happens then
you'll get exactly
what you want here because this term
here will go to infinity if it's wrong
it'll go to zero otherwise
and so you end up with this convex
combination
so if the model is system dynamics model
is correct then alpha converting to zero
makes sense
if it's not correct then
i'm just worried about sort of
oscillatory behavior so so the fact that
it actually
does converge to a constant is that
because i have this id replicates across
n or like would there be a problem if i
only had a single trajectory
uh i am looking at n going to infinity
here so that was uh
yeah so that's so that is saving us here
uh in some sense because i'm using the
so if you use
one single trajectory i think things you
can still work things out
there's going to be a few challenges
here one the estimation of theta hats
can be much more troublesome
so that's one big problem and so you
can't just sort of argue well theta has
gone the right thing
and so i really will get the right value
function for that theta
then and then it will be a root uh i i
think that um
yeah i think things get a lot harder in
that case i'm not saying it's not true
but i don't know if it's true or not
or what kind of adjustments need to be
made so i mean i am relying on that this
is his n goes
not as t goes yeah
that how hard
i think the other thing to note is in a
spatial problem what you want is you
want the number of locations to go to
infinity
so you you may have one long trajectory
but you want to pool over locations
and so the hope there is well you don't
have id data if you have a mark off
random field or some other kind of
structure you still get enough
replicates that that might save you
from having this complex dependence
between the action selection over time
and the estimation of theta hat what
does a trajectory mean in a special
temperature
oh so you still have you have you have t
diverging just
i mean you have regular time progressing
but you also may have a lot of
um you may you might have a lot of time
spatial
locations like an arcade in the white
nose syndrome you had like 1100
locations
and so the number of locations is very
large relative to time
and so you might look at uh asymptotic
frameworks for the number of location
diverges
also and so there that ends up playing
the role of
n in some sense
if that helps
oh okay so we have just a few minutes um
let me just say that um okay so we
choose kappa n so that alpha
kappa alpha hat kappa n goes to zero if
the model's correctly specified and
diverges to infinity otherwise
uh so basically even if it does
oscillate if that thing doesn't converge
to a constant but as long as it's
bounded away from zero you're still okay
i should have said that actually uh it
doesn't have to converge to a constant
it just can't convert to zero
if it's mis-specified uh we do require
the estimated equation of the unique
isolated minimizer
the rates you want to choose depends on
the structure that you have
uh consistency follows immediately but
efficiency is much more difficult
uh there there's hope we use these good
obvious weights so we should
we should hope to have an efficient
estimating equation also if you're
looking at parametric models estimated
by mle those should also be efficient
but we don't know for sure so this is a
this is an open area
and i think that there's there's
certainly room for improvement i think
this idea of a convex combination
of course is maybe a reasonable place to
start but i think there's probably
better ways to combine these two things
uh this is this is certainly a naive
thing to do
um and so you know i i would love it if
there was people who
wanted to think about this problem and
work on this problem uh as i said we're
in
very early stages so i think
maybe i'll just wrap things up here
uh because we only have three minutes
and just say that the slides will be
made available links to the papers will
be made available
and the the technical details for these
things are are
included in the slides for those who are
interested and also you can email me
and i'll do my best to answer any
questions
a lot to digest but it was also at the
same time very interesting especially
this last bit
um this idea of because there are lots
of places where you can put structure in
rl right
we can put it in the model or in the
policy or in the value functions and
this idea that
if one of my guess is correct then then
at least i'm consistent and then if
more of more of my guesses are correct
then i get something even more out of it
i think it's an interesting
very interesting idea um
let me just scan for questions i don't
think
we have any pending ones i see someone's
typing something in discord so maybe we
will have a question soon
um
there's something that i wanted to ask
you now it can escape my mind
oh yeah so it's all right so going back
to the special spatial temporal
uh so you said you have like what 11 000
[Music]
100 locations 1100 1100 locations
and the trajectories are what's the time
scale like
they measure things of the order of days
weeks like and how much do you how much
data
like what is what is t in those yeah so
t there
is uh is years so there's very few
decision
points in the problem so they
they want to update their policy
every year uh and
they have some idea about how much
resources will be available but it also
changes based on their funding
uh and so they're looking to plan at
like a 20-year time horizon or something
or 10-year time horizon
and that's the setting
[Music]
there's actually a lot of nuance there
because the the that i that i
kind of brushed over which is a gloss
over which
is that you know they're collecting this
data
over time throughout the year so it's
convenient to sample caves
during certain times of year but there's
also more likely to be infections during
the winter or other times
and so there's real serious i think
sampling bias in that problem that we
really didn't
account for and uh
because we had to make concessions
somewhere and so that was one of the
places we just kind of assumed that you
observe everything in one chunk for the
year and then you treat that as is more
or less
uh noiseless observation but i think you
know
there's a lot of room there in terms of
of having that systematic bias
sampling uh and and having partial
observability but the partial
observability definitely is is dependent
on time
and so they're collecting data
continuously throughout the year but
then you make a decision once every year
uh is the time scale
i see and and and in one slide you
mentioned that
i think for the in the w robust case for
the value function
estimating equations you said just let's
just use some very powerful
uh approximating class like neural
networks um
in the specific applications you work in
let's say the the
wireless the back virus thing like
is there any sense uh like what kind of
i mean there are other function classes
as well right i mean we have lots of
uh non-productive classes that
eventually would cover all functions
right but in different applications some
some tend to be the others do you have
any any input on that
uh that's a good question i mean i don't
know i'm partial to i'm
partial to random force because some of
the inference is tractable
which is a terrible reason to do
something uh
but um yeah
i i don't know that it's easy to see
what the structure of those things
should be
from a problem like you know if you're
talking a white nose like what should be
the right class of functions to use uh
i think that's an open problem too so
another thing is like
can we use uh so like one thing we've
done before is taking a bunch of
dynamics models
from those dynamics models try to back
up what the q functions are and then use
those as basis functions
in building a more flexible estimator
like so those become
you know if you have q function for
model one key function for model two key
function model three
those now become like feature vectors
for a non-parametric method
so that's one thing but it's it is i
don't know
the you know a good way to take a
particular problem and then say
oh this is amenable to like uh say
neural networks are boosting or random
forests or something else
uh i guess i'm also partial to kernel
type methods
again because the hope is you might be
able to back up some inference which
also
ends up being important in the kind of
things that we work on so
yeah it's a question i mean you can read
it it's on zoom
from thomas uh okay uh
yes there's a question curious to hear
thoughts on evaluating medical
interventions for
rl or how they vary across stakeholders
as the judgmental clinicians vary from
fda
to admin the biostatisticians the
patients the nurses record yeah
so good question this is a
[Music]
this is this is a a very important issue
so
one of the things that i didn't talk
about that i think maybe doesn't get
talked about in precision medicine
enough
so clinicians obviously want to maximize
health outcomes for their patients
but they also really are concerned about
how their time is spent and by that you
know if we tell
all there's going to we're going to give
you this tool to help you make better
decisions for your patients
but this tool is going to require you to
spend an extra 20 minutes with every
patient
uh you know that may not i mean the cost
of that may be so high
that they're being they're totally
unwilling to adopt it unless it's going
to save lives you know
um so there's there's there's a lot of
like implementation costs
that are there uh certainly for if
you're talking about stakeholders like
uh
some kind of insurance company or or um
you know medical provider some group
in terms of how much it's going to cost
so when we worked on
uh this dental recommendation system
with health partners
you know one of the one of the things we
looked at was how much
the cost associated with an intervention
strategy
that was adaptive you know so if you're
saying just if you're going to say to
some people
come back in three months whereas before
we were telling everybody come back in
six months
well that's going to be more expensive
people are coming back twice as often so
you have to have some other
you know patients that are coming back
only every year let's say right
and and but on the other hand there's
long-term savings maybe
if if you're preventing serious uh
procedures by
being more proactive and oral health so
uh they care a lot about they they want
you know their patients to do well
uh either because it's less costly from
an insurance point of view or also
you know if we want to give them the
benefit of being uh
you know caring about their patients the
the the insurance providers
but but that that is a that is a major
concern
and so uh i was at a talk and and
this kind of i can't remember the
person's name now uh
but he does a lot of implementation work
uh for mhealth and other kinds of
works with hospitalists and that kind of
thing but his rule was that if you can't
get a three
or four fold reduction i think in terms
of uh outcome that no one will pay the
adoption costs
so these are real this is an important
question that you bring up and
uh it doesn't get talked about enough i
think
uh you know
i don't know if that answers the
question or not but hopefully
i think do you know of an actual study
either planned or maybe even completed
that had a primary aim that had
something to do with uh
uh like a dynamic treatment regime and
sample size calculation one time like is
this still in the future type of
situation is this half already happening
or about to happen
no we have we have trials in the field
using this kind of uh sizing methodology
uh and yeah so
so it is happening so we have one trial
that's almost done now
that was run out of northwestern
uh on mhealth interventions or partially
mhealth interventions
uh among adolescent men who have sex
with men
and so there's a this also gets
the previous question so it's delivering
this this these messaging safe sex
intervention on the phone but then it
escalates to potentially having cbt or
other kinds of more expensive
interventions
for non-responders and part of all this
is well
you know if we're going to roll this an
intervention like that out and
a national or international scale cost
is really important
so uh there's obviously you know the
investigators care about the
the health outcomes of these patients
but there's also this concern that to
make that impact it has to be cost
effective and so we should really only
be
uh intervening with with expensive
interventions if and when it's
going gonna be most impactful
[Music]
thank you uh i don't see any more
questions coming in so we can
oh there's there is one on chat oh
that's just a discussion between the
there's an active discussion going on on
the chat between the
attendees and which is good i mean i
think we've had a
very active audience throughout the week
i hope it stays that way all the way
through friday
um okay thanks a lot eric that was
a lot four hours speaking in a day with
home and
kids in the background i know it's not
easy so i really appreciate it
well thank you thanks everybody thank
you
um just i'll just remind you i mean i
think a lot of students especially they
want references so i'm asking all
speakers to include them in the final
version of slides so just
um if you could do that yeah
hey thanks a lot eric okay thanks
bye everybody